Hey everyone, I'm Ishaan the CEO of
Amnara and today I'm going to be talking
about the log is the agent. The basic
idea of the talk is simple and that is
most people think of an agent as the
model or the execution environment that
it's running in and I think that that's
the wrong abstraction. I think that the
thing that actually gives an agent its
identity is its log and that's what I'm
going to be arguing today.
So think about a character you've spent
a hundred hours playing in your favorite
video game, in this case Skyrim. What
exactly is your character? Is it the
game engine? Is it the PlayStation? Is
it the controller?
No, it's not. Those things matter and
those things are what will interact with
and they'll run the character but none
of those things are your character. Your
character is data. It's the save file.
And this is important because if your
PlayStation bursts into flames, your
character isn't gone. You can buy
another PlayStation, you can download
your save file from the cloud and you
can resume exactly where they were and
that's because the agent and its
identity and history and its state is
all captured in its data. The character
lives in the data and this is the
framing that I want to bring to agents.
Today when people talk about agents,
they usually point at the wrong thing.
They'll say that the agent is the model
or they'll say that it's the runtime and
again as I mentioned earlier, those
things matter but they're not the agent.
The agent is its data. It's specifically
the log. So what actually is the log? At
the simplest level, the log is the
append-only event history of the agent.
It's every user input, every model
output, every tool called, tool result,
permission, failure
and the idea is that every state
transition that the agent takes is
written to the log.
This is important because it means that
the
identity of the agent isn't tied to the
runtime or the model or the tools. Those
things are all just interpreting and
appending to the log. They're reading
the log, acting on it, and writing the
next event back. And that's important
because then just using the log on its
own is enough to resume the agent. Once
you define the agent as a log, the rest
of the system becomes a whole lot easier
to reason about because every operation
is either reading from or appending to
the log.
The model is reading from the log and
then determining the next action. The
tool runner is then executing that
action and then it's appending that
result. And this is all operating in a
loop. Everything coordinates itself
around the log. In practice, a
simplified loop can look something like
this. You can reconstruct the state from
the log. You can pass that state to the
model. The model can propose the next
step and then append that response to
the log. If the response asks for a
tool, you can run that tool and also
append that response to the log and then
you can repeat. The important insight is
not that this loop is complicated. The
important insight is that the loop is
disposable. A worker can claim the
session, read the log, advance the agent
one step, write the result, and then
just completely disappear. And then that
means that any other worker can pick it
up later.
This pattern should feel familiar.
Databases had to learn this first. For
years, databases looked like these
non-transparent systems that were hard
to reason about with tables and indexes
and materialized views, but underneath
every serious database
is a log. And
that log is the durable sequence of
changes. Everything else is a view.
I I agents need the same inversion.
Today, agents are treated as again,
these complicated systems that are
opaque and they're filled with models
and prompts and tool calls,
but for the durable session, the log
should be primary. The context that gets
fed into the model is a projection of
that log. The UI that gets rendered on
top is a projection of that log.
Debugging and traceability is a
projection. Auditing is a projection.
Compaction is also projection, which
we'll talk about. But the log itself is
not a projection. The log is the durable
history that all of these projections
can come from.
Now, there are two objections to the log
as the agent that are worth discussing.
So, I'm going to talk about them now.
Now, let's start with compaction. A log
can grow indefinitely, but a model's
view of it can't. Context windows are
finite. So, eventually, you do need to
compact the log into a smaller
representation that the model can reason
about. But the important point is that
this compaction is not magic and it
doesn't break the claim that the log is
the agent. Compaction is lossy. A
compacted summary is not going to
perfectly reproduce the state of the
agent in a smaller form. It's actually
going to throw information away. The
point is the full log is the record and
a compaction is just one projection of
it. Just like how a materialized view is
not the database or a summary of a
conversation is not the conversation. If
you keep the raw log, you can always
generate new projections from it. But if
you throw away the raw log and keep only
the compaction, you've effectively lost
part of the agent. So, it's cleanest to
treat compaction as a best effort lossy
fork, one that you can resume as a new
log.
The second objection is what about tools
that change state outside of the log?
And that's true. An agent can edit a
file. It can create a GitHub issue. It
can send an email. So, clearly, there is
state outside of the log. But, the point
is is that the log is not supposed to
contain the whole world. The log is just
the agent's view of the world. It's just
like how in the video game in in Skyrim,
the Skyrim save file doesn't contain the
entire game engine or every asset in the
map. It just contains the player
specific state, which is needed to drop
you back into that world. And the same
is true for the log and agents. The log
can only faithfully resume or store that
agent's identity and its view of the
world, but it cannot make that world
deterministic. If the agent sent an
email, forking back won't unsend it. If
some file got changed underneath, the
agent won't know about it. But, the
log's job is to record what the agent
did, what it saw, what changed, and what
it needs to continue. It stores that
identity, and that's its purpose. And
much like that Skyrim character save
file, it's not meant to store the entire
world. It's just meant to store its view
of it.
So, once you start treating the log as a
primitive, a whole bunch of system
properties will fall out naturally. So,
the first property is reliability.
Consider what happens today with Cloud
Code. If you're using Cloud Code and
your agent reaches a permission prompt
and the process dies for whatever
reason, and then you resume it, the
permission prompt will be gone, and the
agent will be paused.
And that is unacceptable in production.
The permission prompt should stay there.
So, this is just a sign of when you
architect your agent in a way where the
log isn't the agent. When the log is the
agent, the executor is allowed to be
fallible. A new worker will pick up the
session. It'll reconstruct the state,
and it'll see that the permission prompt
is there right where it was.
So, even though the process died, the
agent didn't along with it. The second
property is scalability. Most harnesses
will run one process per agent, which
means that the agent is tied to the
machine running it. When the log is the
state, you flip that model. One process
can now advance thousands of agents.
Each of them can reconstruct their state
from the log on each turn, and they
don't need to be tied to any single
machine or worker. This makes failover
trivial, and it also makes scaling just
a matter of adding more workers. There's
no sticky sessions, there's no state
migration, and there's no coordination
overhead. Forking becomes a whole lot
more natural, too. Instead of having to
force like one linear path, you can
easily branch the log. One branch can
run on Claude, another branch can run on
GPT, another can run on your favorite
open-source model. Each of the branches
can store some of the history up until
the fork point, and then they can
explore different strategies.
Multiplayer is another property. Sharing
an agent with someone should not mean
having to copy some transcript and paste
it into Slack. If the log is the agent,
sharing means you simply grant access to
that history, so that somebody else can
view it and edit it. A teammate can open
the session, they can see what happened,
a manager can observe without taking
over, and even another agent could
consume the same session as context.
This is really important because it
means that the value is not just what
the agent produced, it's also the log,
which indicates how it got there.
Migration follows the same pattern. If
an agent's identity is trapped in
provider-specific
threads and memories and formats and
runtime assumptions, moving providers
becomes really painful. But if the log
is the agent, migration is just a
adapter problem. Different models may
want different projections of the log,
and different runtimes may need
different schemas,
but those are all become just
engineering problems. They're not
identity problems. The agent should then
be able to start on Claude, continue on
GPT, and finish on Gwen without losing
itself. The log serves as a source of
continuity.
Here's the problem with a lot of current
agent infrastructure. Most agent
harnesses today will treat the log as an
afterthought. So, Claude code and Codex
will write these messy JSONL files to
local disk, and even in Claude SDK mode,
those writes are fire and forget, which
means that if for whatever reason the
write fails, the data is gone. Open
code's another example, they store state
in a SQLite file, and there's a lot of
GitHub issues around how there's corrupt
state and data loss. Durable objects
often end up holding different shards,
that makes reconstructing history
difficult, it makes querying across
sessions difficult. And in all of these
scenarios, the log is just a side
effect, it's not the system. And that's
a problem, because when you treat the
log as a first-class citizen, it makes
all of these properties become
structural. You don't have to bolt them
on, which is what it feels like is being
done today, they all just
fall out.
The next point is incredibly important.
This brings us to ownership. The
strongest form, now that we've
established that the log is the agent,
the strongest form of lock-in isn't
model lock-in. Models can be swapped.
It's not API or tool lock-in either.
Those can be wrapped, and those can be
adapted. The deepest form of lock-in
is actually log lock-in. If a provider
owns your log, then the provider
effectively owns your agent and
long-term the log is the valuable part
because the model is replaceable, the
runtimes replaceable, the machines are
replaceable, the log is the thing that
persists. I have another slide for this
because I think it's really worth taking
seriously right now. Anthropic has
Claude managed agents, Google has Gemini
managed agents, every managed provider
is going to own more of the stock.
They're going to want to. They're going
to want to have the hosted agent loop
and manage memory and sand boxes and
compaction and background agents.
They're going to want to own your agents
and
agents are arguably the most intimate
piece of technology you'll ever run. For
an agent to be useful, it needs to have
your personal data, your company's data,
your workflows, your decisions. The log
is the record of all of that and if it
lives on someone else's infrastructure
under their policies and queryable by
their systems, they don't just host your
agent. They own it. This is the
architecture we have been building
towards at Unara. We think of agent
execution as the set of components that
are coordinated around the log.
The worker advances the loop, but the
worker is not the agent, it's just the
executor and it will call out to the
model provider, it'll get its results,
it'll write it back to the log and then
if the model provider requires tools, it
will go ahead and dispatch those tools
to the right execution environment to
finish somewhere else. The tools will
complete and then those results will get
appended back to the log and then a
worker, most likely a different one,
will then reconstruct the state and
it'll continue and this is very
important because this is how real agent
systems will have to survive real-world
failure because workers will crash,
machines will restart, sandboxes
disappear, tool calls will time out,
providers will fail, users connect.
There's so many different things that
can go wrong. And if an agent is a
running process, that's extremely
terrifying. But if the agent is the log,
it's simply an execution detail.
And
this is important because it's the core
of what we're building. It's the core of
the open-source managed agents platform
that we're debuting. Everything will be
built around the session log, which we
will make sure that you can fully own,
fully inspect, it's fully controlled by
you.
And
that's something we believe in strongly.
If you're interested, check it out at
amnar.com/managed.
It may be released by the time this
recording comes out or there may still
be a waitlist there.
So, in closing, the main thing I want to
leave you with is this.
An agent is not just a model call, it's
not just a prompt or a loop or a
sandbox. It's not any of those things.
The agent is the durable history of the
work being done, and that history is the
log. Once you start to see it this way,
a whole lot of things fall into place.
Reliability, compaction, forking,
migration, multiplayer, ownership,
scalability, so many things. Because
you're going to stop treating the log as
this exhaust from the system, and you're
going to treat it as the system itself.
And that's super important. So, if this
was useful, stay tuned to what we're
building at Amnara. We're getting ready
to open source, as I mentioned, our
managed agents platform, and you can
join here. The log as the agent is just
one of several pieces that we think are
going to be making agents a whole lot
more powerful in the future. So, thanks
for tuning in.